We know that the snake is
utilized conceptually and metaphorically
as representation of transformation,
right,
because the snake is something that
can shed its skin and be reborn.
We know that a snake is something that's
innately attractive and terrifying
human beings and other primates so
that if you come across a snake,
you're likely to be at least startled,
if not horrified by it,
but also attracted to it in a way
that is underneath your voluntary
consciousness,
right?
Because snakes attract orienting
reflex isn't they activate the systems
underneath your consciousness that
actually govern the structure of that
consciousness.
We know that the snake can be well
represented as well as internal chaos,
so imagine this,
imagine that it's not unreasonable for
a self conscious mind searching for a
mode of self representation to remark on
the parallels between the structure of
the snake and the spine and the brain.
Given that a snake is essentially a spine
with a brain and then imagine as well
that the most archaic aspects
of our nervous system,
those that govern novelty and orienting
and anxiety responses are in fact
precisely those that were described by
Mclean as nested inside the reptilian
brain and then imagine
along with the Hindu Yogis,
that the purpose of Kundalini Yoga
is to activate the circuitry that's
associated with that snake,
so to speak,
to produce a permanent
state of alert wakefulness.
It's associated with consciousness,
so imagine this.
Imagine an animal like like a zebra
grazing mindlessly in the herd with no
consciousness whatsoever,
and then imagine it's relatively
undeveloped cortical structures activated
suddenly by the movement of a lion off
in the perimeter and then imagine for
that brief moment the thought
Zebra is actually conscious state.
That requires a tremendous amount
of energy and difficult to maintain,
but because the threat and the uncertainty
manifest itself within the zebras
mode of consciousness,
it wakes momentarily.
And then imagine that
human beings are like that.
Zebra always because we've become self
conscious because we know that the
unknown is around us all the time.
Even when we think we're safe,
we're never safe.
Imagine that the reason we're so conscious
is because as a consequence of our
discovery,
of the possibility of our own mortality,
all this underlying circuitry that in
other animals is only apparent when
they're startled or afraid
or interested or curious.
In human beings.
It's on all the time and that's what
makes us conscious and the reason for that
is because we developed enough cortical
elaboration to note that we're always
threatened by everything that's around us.
And then imagine that.
Well,
that's pretty awful,
isn't it?
Because it's at the basis of
all our innate existential,
but then imagine as well that without
that terror pushing us forward and and our
constant reference to the
dangerous aspect of the unknown,
we would have never been motivated to
produce the kind of societies that we've
produced,
which are essentially very remarkably
elaborated devices that enable us to find
some protection from that
unknown and to manipulate,
manipulate it effectively,
and then remembering that Surrey,
we will return to genesis young says
the snake was regarded by early gnostic
Christians as a kind of deity whose
faculties were more developed and advanced
than the original daddy that
actually structured the world.
The idea there being that the world
initially was a pretty dismal place.
Everyone wasn't conscious.
We all existed at the level of the
animal and then the snake came along and
said,
wake up.
Wake up.
And the movement from that state of
unsolved consciousness paradise to this
profane state of awakening can be regarded
not so much as a descent but as an
asset of sorts,
even though a painful one.
And then you have Gareth.
This commentary from Mephistopheles,
his representation of Satan and
his capacity for temptation,
who says,
follow the adage of my cousin,
snake from dreams of godlike knowledge,
you will wake to fear in which your
very soul shall quake a statement,
associating the human
tendency to attribute to all
revolutionary sources of new
information,
a kind of demonic being,
and then you have the
problem of the woman.
Now we know that within the context
of the Judeo Christian tradition,
women have unduly suffered for their
role in tempting humanity in the embodied
form of Adam towards higher
order self consciousness,
and then you think,
well,
let's just take a look at how human beings
and their mating relationships differ
from those of other animals like
chimpanzees to whom we are very closely
genetically related.
And if you look at the mating
strategies of female chimpanzees,
you see that they really don't
care who they sleep with,
so to speak.
Any old chimpanzee will do.
Now,
the last dominant male chimps tend to be
chased away by the more dominant nailed
chimps,
but if a female than less dominant chimp
can get the hell away from the watchful
gaze of the dominance hierarchy,
they're perfectly happy to mate.
Human females are not like that.
There is selective of maters and there's
a tremendous body of evolutionary
psychological information that
suggests that although both genders,
value intelligence and
physical appearance,
females value the ability
to attain dominance,
hierarchy status in men far more than men,
admire the ability to attain
dominant status in women,
which is to say that men don't care what
a woman has with regards to potential
for attaining status.
Whereas with women,
it's one of the strong
determinant of mating preference.
So then let's say,
look,
we don't know why the hell are
cortex has expanded so rapidly,
somewhere between five
and 3 million years ago.
Let's offer this as a hypothesis.
The women started to get choosy and
because they were so damn complicated,
the whole human species had to exaggerate
it's critical growth prior to any even
use for that critical growth,
just so that the men had
uneven hand in the competition,
right?
So women put tremendous selection
pressure on the human being to develop
tremendous,
tremendous cortical expansion.
Now we already know that from a
mythological perspective that women are
frequently cast into the
same conceptual domain,
the temptress domain as the
benevolent aspect of the unknown,
and we know as well from representations
of hero mythology that it is the
individual who goes out to confront chaos,
who's most likely to free from the dragon,
not only treasured,
but a virgin,
say in the case of mythological
representations like St
George and the dragon
in the Old Testament in genesis,
there's no.
There's this notion that not only did
people become self conscious because they
did something,
but they did this voluntarily,
right?
They,
they,
they made this decision on their own.
So Milton puts words into
God's mouth and says,
so will fall.
He meaning the human being
and his faithless progeny,
whose fault?
Whose about his own engrave he had of me,
oh,
he could have.
I made him Justin,
right?
It's efficient to have
stood though free to fall,
and then you think,
well,
maybe the notion of the heritable sin
of Adam characterizing human beings and
their fallen existential condition
isn't just the black heart ravings of
fundamentalist southern Baptist lunatics,
right?
There's something to this.
Human beings are the only creatures
that seem to live at odds with their own
experience and it's not so unreasonable
to suppose that it's hard dawning
capacity for self consciousness that
put us in that uncomfortable position.
So why do I associate the eating of
the apple with selfconsciousness?
Well,
let's.
Because that's how the
story lays itself out.
You have the collateral evidence of
the Buddhist story of enlightenment,
right?
His contact with death.
You have multiple media,
medieval representations of
Eve offering to animal to Adam.
Not An apple,
but a skull.
You have multiple
representations of the tree,
of the knowledge of good and evil in
medieval iconography as not containing
apples,
but containing skulls and you have
the the statements that are within the
context of genesis itself.
And the eyes of both of them were opened
and they knew that they were naked and
they sewed fig leaves together
and made themselves aprons.
Well,
there's a lot of information
packed into those two lines,
right?
What does it mean to have your eyes open?
Or half?
Your brain is visual cortex.
It's not on.
It's not unreasonable to
presume that that means a quick,
a quick magnification of consciousness.
Your conscious during the day,
that's when your eyes are open or
what happens when your eyes are open?
Oh,
you know you're naked.
Well,
what does that mean?
you know,
you're vulnerable,
right?
To social comment,
to social judgment,
to dominance,
hierarchy,
status maneuvering,
and to all the terrible things
that the unknown world can,
can recap on you.
And so then what do you do?
Oh,
you create culture,
right?
And that's what this little sentence says.
And they sewed fig leaves together
and made themselves aprons.
That's a pretty eventful sequence all
crammed up in two little sentences.
So then what happens?
I think it's extremely interesting.
So before Adam and eve figure
out that they're naked,
they're cruising around the garden.
Having a fine time doing
whatever they want.
They don't take any
thoughts for the future,
right?
I don't have a prefrontal cortex.
They're living in a in a paradox lists
environment like an animal lives.
Well,
what happens after they
become self conscious?
Well,
prior to this,
Adam's walking around with God,
right,
and you think about what that means.
It means something like this.
An animal isn't in the world of good
and evil and animal nature points out is
beyond good and evil,
right?
Enraptured in entirely by the actions
of automatic instinct governed by
processes that are
completely transcendent.
The animals,
nothing but a force of nature.
There is no opposition between
the animal in the world.
The animal is the world,
and just as in the case of the animal,
prior to the eating of the apple,
Adam walks around the garden with God.
There's no discontinuity between him and
the and the transcendent world as such,
but as soon as he becomes naked,
he hides well.
Why?
Well,
that doesn't need to be answered.
All you have to think about it.
Why would you hide if
you know you're naked?
Well,
it's simple.
You'll hide because you
think you can get hurt.
You think that whatever you are is so
vulnerable that if it shows itself to the
transcendent to others,
to the natural world,
that something terrible will happen,
and then you think,
well,
that's a pretty logical presupposition,
right?
Look at us.
So God comes cruising around
the garden after Adam and Eve,
the apple in the cool of the day and
Adam and Eve hide themselves among the
trees of the garden and God says to Adam,
Hey,
where are you?
Adam says,
I heard your voice,
and I was afraid because I
was naked and I hid myself,
and that story has bottomless depth
because it means something like this.
At the beginning of genesis,
there's this notion that there is a
transcendent relationship between the
individual and God,
right?
The identity of logo 70 individual,
I know it shouldn't by the way,
that our entire idea of
intrinsic human right,
it's predicated on it as we've been at
some pains to demonstrate a relationship
between the limited and the limitless
eradicated by the dawn of self
consciousness.
What does that mean?
Well,
let's say you have a destiny
just for the sake of argument,
right?
Because you are a being with a tremendous
history and an unbelievable potential.
So let's say you have a destiny
just for the sake of argument,
what would cause you to
hide from that destiny?
Well,
obviously
your own reflections on
your mortal vulnerability,
right?
How could I be characterized by any
transcendent power whatsoever when I'm
susceptible to social alienation,
right?
When I have this body which is capable
of terrifying degeneration that will
eventually decay into old edge
and that is bounded by death.
How could I be good for anything which
is precisely what this little story says,
and so God figures out that Adam and
eve ate the fruit and that's pretty
decisive move because once you wake up,
sorry,
you're awake,
and he says,
and this is not an injunction,
by the way,
this is a description,
all right,
you've done it now unto the woman.
He says,
I will greatly multiply the Isaura night
conception in sorrow shalt thou bring
forth children.
Why?
Well,
we have a big CORTEX,
right?
Really big.
It grew fast and what that meant is
that there was an evolutionary arms race
between skull size,
date of birth,
and pelvic diameter girth.
The wider the pelvis,
the less effectively you
can walk a larger the skull.
The bigger the brain,
the younger the baby,
the more dependent and vulnerable.
So what do we have in
the case of human beings,
the female human pelvis has already
stretched to the limits of its structural
capacity.
So the hole in its center is as big
as it can get without compromising the
structural integrity of the pelvis while
still allowing women to walk and run.
So how have babies adapted to that?
Oh,
that's simple.
A mammo of our size should have
a gestation period of two years.
We have a gestation period of nine months.
Why you got to get the damn baby
out before it's head gets too big?
What does that mean?
Well,
it means it's vulnerable,
right?
Nothing more vulnerable than a baby human
being except maybe a baby kitten room.
Right?
But it's got a pouch to hide in at least.
So we're born vulnerable,
right?
Characteristic of the birth of the hero.
Who suffers in childbirth?
Women.
Why?
Baby skulls?
Just a little bit too big,
has to be crunched and
compacted during birth,
right?
The skull bones aren't joined together
so that the baby's head can be squashed
and visibly deformed during
the process of birth.
Prior to the 20th century,
what was the death rate
among women giving birth?
One in three,
one in five.
Terrible.
Why?
That's the price you pay
for self consciousness
and I desire shall be to the
husband and he shall rule over thee.
This is not an injunction.
This is a description.
The additional burden that
dependent offspring place on women,
place them at a disadvantage.
What's the consequence of that
from a historical perspective?
Well,
any feminist can answer that question,
right?
Add on to Adam.
He said,
because you listened to your wife and
have eaten the tree of which I commanded
thee,
saying,
don't eat that.
Cursed is the ground for the sake in
sorrow shall though he'd have it for all
the days of thy life.
Fair enough,
right?
Once you're self conscious,
you work.
Why?
Well,
animals don't work.
Why do people work well?
Because we know,
right,
we know that if it isn't
gonna happen today,
it's going to happen tomorrow and if
it isn't going to happen tomorrow,
what's going to happen next week or
the week after the month after the year
after and we bloody well better prepare.
So that's what we do.
Constantly prepare and prepare and prepare
so we're not bounded and motivated by
what's happening from second to
second like the animal is in.
It's still paradisical state.
We're constantly tormented by an
endless string of what if questions,
because when we look at the unknown,
we can see the possibility for everything
including our own punishment or own
tournament,
our own demise,
and so we're motivated like no
other animal to work and so we work.
But that is another aspect that
alienates us from paradise.
Wellbeing
thorns and thistles shall it
bring forth for the analysis.
You'll eat the herb of the field in the
sweat of thy face shalt thou eat bread
til thou return unto the ground for
Dust Thou art and unto dust shall thou
return,
right?
Therefore,
the Lord God sent him forth from the
garden of Eden to till the ground from
whence he was taken.
So he drove out the man and he placed
at the east of the garden of Eden
Cherubims and a flaming sword which turned
every way to keep the way of the tree
of life.